Pois é, você provavelmente está usando o
ingrediente errado para cozinhar esse
tempo todo. Olha só que curioso. Um
estudo brasileiro comparou banha de
porco com óleo de soja. E veja bem, a
banha ganhou disparado. As mulheres que
usaram o banho por 45 dias tiveram
redução do colesterol ruim e aumento do
bom. Já quem usou óleo de soja, o
colesterol bom despencou 20%. Sabe por
quê? O óleo de soja é cheio de ômega-6,
que em excesso inflama o corpo todo. Já
a banha aguenta altas temperaturas sem
oxidar e não vira toxina quando você
frita. É gordura saturada, sim, mas o
nosso corpo precisa dela para produzir
hormônios e proteger as células. Então,
na próxima vez que for refogar ou fritar
algo, experimente usar uma colherinha de
banha no lugar do óleo.